a lot of people in our audience use
Craigslist Craigslist pretty popular so
I thought we would help our audience
members make a sale or connection by
showing some of their craigslist ads
right here on the show right now so a
good idea to you Larry the Cable Guy
just cancel a bunch of shows in your
area hire me no one will know the
difference movie needs financing it
tells the story of my fist and the
journey it takes to your face service
offered service offered you suffer from
insomnia I'll sit by your bedside and
complain about the price of lunch meats
until you fall asleep
put higher for higher to badass Smurfs
[Applause]
need a guy to tie you to the railroad
tracks and cackle maniacally I'm your
man
[Music]
fun-loving guy seeks friendship you know
that app for your iPhone where you swap
faces let's do that except with your
actual skin man seeking woman
seeking a kind pretty woman who won't
make me feel weird about what I call my
genitals Frankie Beebe and woo woo
[Applause]
[Music]
you